tu es juive donc je ne te coifferai pas
c'est sous le choc que Yael 31 ans est
sorti ce jour de novembre de chez sa
coiffeuse à Gan en scène saintonie
vexation discrimination voire agression
depuis le début du conflit entre le
Hamas et Israël l'antisémitisme du
quotidien hante les Français juifs 74 %
d'entre eux disent avoir déjà subi un
comportement antisémite de la moquerie à
l'agression physique et 48 % préfèrent
dissimuler leur identité lors de
certaines discussions le phénomène n'est
pas nouveau en janvier 2021 à Strasbourg
un livreur delivero avait refusé de
prendre des commandes dans deux
restaurants cacher objectant je ne livre
pas les Juifs ce jeune algérien avait
été condamné à 4 mois de prison ferme
puis expulsé du territoire français mais
beaucoup de cas ne remontent pas jusqu'à
la justice par peur des représailles les
victimes ne portent pas toujours plainte
c'est le cas de ce père de famille qui à
son retour de Tel Aviv a été refusé
ainsi que sa famille par un chauffeur de
taxi à l'aéroport d'Orly sale juif si je
t'avais pris je t'aurais égorgé tout toi
ta femme et tes enfants lui avaient
alors lancé le chauffeur suspendu peu
après par la direction des usagers et
des polices administratives la poste
n'est pas en reste les colis envoyés en
Israël arrivent très souvent très
longtemps après parfois en piteux état
avec Israël barré et remplacé par
Palestine témoigne une quincagéère
parisienne le nouvel antisémitisme c'est
un fonctionnaire ou un salarié qui
utilise son entreprise pour faire son
petit jihad perso contre le Juif de son
choix pour éviter les ennuis et assurer
leur sécurité certains Français juifs
font le difficile choix de la
dissimulation quand on s'appelle Levi ou
Cohen en ce moment il vaut mieux prendre
un pseudo soupire une mère de famille
qui a inscrit des initiales sur son
interphone une stratégie qui inquiète le
représentant des institutions juives en
France retirer la mesoua de la porte
cacher l'équipage sous les casquettes
effacer les nonoms Juifs sur les boîtes
aux lettres ou les applications mobiles
pourrai nous conduire à un grand
[Musique]
effacement